Today we're going to look at a well known case,
Allegheny college versus national,
uh,
Chautauqua County Bank of Jamestown,
which was decided by the highest court of the state of New York in 1927.
We will use the case to talk more broadly about some issues related to
promissory Estoppel.
The case concerns a promise to make a charitable bequest.
Allegheny college,
a college in Northwestern Pennsylvania,
ran a fundraising drive in 1921 and persuaded Merrie Yates Johnston,
who lived in New York to promise to make a donation of $5,000 upon her death.
She signed a document to that effect and two witnesses signed as well.
She donated $1,000 in 1923 while she was still alive and she later retracted her
promise.
Now,
when the case is being argued,
Ms. Johnston has passed away and the college was trying to enforce her promise
against the bank that was serving as the executor of her estate.
In this case,
a judge Benjamin Cardozo.
Later Justice Cardozo had to decide whether Mrs Johnston's promise was
enforceable for lack of consideration.
Cardozo spends a significant portion of his decision discussing the doctrine of
promissory Estoppel,
which he sees as a new direction in which contract law's evolving.
Promissory Estoppel is quote,
a substitute for consideration or an exception to its ordinary requirements
unquote.
Ordinarily,
ordinarily,
as we've discussed in past weeks,
a valid contract must include consideration which is bargained for benefit to
the promise or illegal detriment to the promise.
See,
promissory Estoppel is quite different under this doctrine.
A promise is enforceable if the promise he incurs expense to the knowledge of
the promissory note and in reasonable belief that the promise would be kept.
Doughnut of promises to nonprofit institutions such as schools and churches
often give rise to this kind of reliance as the don't ease embark on big
construction projects that depend on the promised money.
Notice that the focus in these cases is on the promises reliance interest.
They have adjusted their behavior in response to a promise and therefore are
harmed.
When some promises are broken,
they might be left with half a building because the funding for the rest did not
come through.
Cardoza notes that judges in New York have adopted the doctrine of promissory
Estoppel as the equivalent of consideration in connection with our law of
charitable subscription.
In doing so,
the judges have been influenced by conceptions of public policy.
They believe that charitable organizations do important and beneficial work that
would not be possible without an ability to rely on promise donations.
Organizations need to be able to plan for the future.
Today,
promissory Estoppel in New York is no longer restricted only to context such as
charitable subscriptions,
but it does have some additional elements not required.
In section 90 of the restatement of contracts in New York,
the promise must be clear and unambiguous and the reliance must be foreseeable
to the promise or and reasonable by the promise.
See,
and the resulting injury must be unconscionable.
It's possible that promissory estoppel would have developed more quickly,
but for judge Cardozo's failure to use it in Allegheny college.
So why didn't judge Cardozo use the doctrine of promissory Estoppel?
One possibility is that section 90 of the first restatement requires a definite
and substantial reliance,
which is difficult to find.
In a case like this,
we can also ask what sort of damages,
uh,
should be available to plaintiff in cases based on promissory Estoppel,
the first restatement and some treatises of treated suits based on promissory
Estoppel as exactly like other contractual promissory claims with expectation
damages as the default rule.
But others have since argued that because the doctrine of promissory Estoppel is
based on the promises reliance,
the appropriate measure of damages is restricted to the promises reliance
interest.
The second restatement suggests that promissory Estoppel follows the same rules
for damages as other breach of contract cases.
But comment d to the section 90 section suggests the damages might quote
sometimes to be limited to restitution or to damages or specific relief measured
by the extent of the promises reliance rather than by the terms of the promise.
One of the main reasons for expectation damages is to ensure that courts fully
compensate hidden reliance on uh,
in bargain for contracts.
In non bargain contracts,
courts,
uh,
can just protect reliance unless there's reason to suspect hidden reliance,
in which case they,
you can use the expectation damaged measure to give this fuller protection.
So in practice,
what kind of damages are awarded today in promissory Estoppel cases,
legal scholars have read hundreds of promissory estoppel cases trying to
discover,
uh,
the answer to this question without coming to a clear consensus,
but it's reasonable to conclude that for non charity promises,
uh,
the damages may be less generous than what is given under contract law.
Cardozo does not end up ruling based on promissory Estoppel.
Rather,
he argues that there was consideration in this case.
Ms. Johnson specified that her quote gift should be known as the Merrie Yates
Johnston Memorial Fund unquote.
He argues that by implication the college undertook when it accepted a portion
of the gift that in its circular is of information and another customary ways
when making announcements of the scholarship,
it would couple with the announcement,
the name of the donor.
Does this remind you of another Cardozo opinion?
Well,
it should.
Cardosa also found an implied return promise to serve as consideration in wood
versus Lucy lady death.
Gordon.
There it was the implied promise to use reasonable efforts in an exclusive
dealing agreement.
Here it is an implied promise to publicize the donor's name.
From these two cases we can start thinking of Cardozo as the great employer.
There seems to be no nude promise that he can't close with implied return
consideration.
Commenters.
Commentators have tended to view Cardoza's characterization of the transaction
quite skeptically and we can see this already in judge Kellogg's dissent in this
case.
First of all,
Kellogg's thinks that Miss Johnson's use of the term gift undermines the idea
that the donation was intended to be a quid pro quo.
Further her inclusion that the line in her promise to donate was an almost was
it most an offer?
The college never accepted it,
but he views ms Johnston's communication with the college as insufficiently
concrete and specific to really count as part of the bargaining that where that
was leading up to a contract and so there was not even an offer.
Colleges and other nonprofits do frequently bargain with donors for naming
rights,
but it seems highly unlikely that such a bargain took place and Mrs Johnson's
case bargained for naming rights look much more like ordinary contracts and
would better fit the mold into which Cardozo tries to shove this case.
So which of the following is not an element of promissory Estoppel?
The promissory should foresee that the promise see would rely the promise.
See,
does in fact rely on the promise,
the promissory and promise he bargained for the promise,
the promise,
he was reasonable and relying on the promise.
Well,
the answer is c promissory Estoppel applies in exactly those cases where there
is no bargain for exchange between the two parties.
The other items are key things that courts look for in evaluating suit based on
promissory Estoppel.
So we have seen that promissory Estoppel allows courts to enforce promises even
in the absence of consideration.
Instead of courts look at the promise,
sees a reasonable and genuine reliance on the promise and the promise or his
knowledge of or ability to foresee that the promise or would rely.
We've also seen that courts may use either the expectation measure or the
reliance measure in assessing damages.
In these cases,
though,
we've also seen that there has been some shift over time toward limiting damages
to alliance.